okay for people joining this live stream
we are looking at a feature of version
12 of language that has to do with
generating standalone applications using
wolfram script and in otherwise so let's
have a quick look through here so
biowulf from script the idea is that if
you say well from script - UI
okay so let's look at this first of all
so first of all Wolfram script - and B
simply execute the notebook right
look evaluate does okay and then returns
to output say that in a reasonable way
in the documentation for from script
it's not documented yet so that's that's
one thing we need to do okay okay then
with the - UI option it will just open a
notebook I think that's the right thing
I mean shouldn't we say I think that's
gonna cause us trouble
so another thing it might do is to
simply run the notebook see what I'm
saying
take the notebook and just you know as
if it's select every cell and run it
yeah that's question one oh okay okay
we basically need additional like maybe
you know - executors basically that
that's exactly what you're saying like
run the cells if there are cells in it
but that you can see it basically that's
what the first I think that this right
here should do should run all the cell's
it does but it doesn't displayed the
notebook so this is something to run it
like headless just if you did it
correctly just okay so hold on a second
this executes the input of the notebook
okay but then the thing it returns is on
the isit is the I see I see I see so it
ran the notebook okay
so do you want me to actually write
documentation for this do you have any
idea where the verification where is it
do you know how do I find it good
question um I think we may have to ask
Brian um can somebody get hold of you
sure um it's still
the program pages so it's the the fourth
or fifth one down from the top program
Fitness and then gets program page and
then type of open script amazing okay
okay gosh okay what's this - notebook so
I think that's the full sorry go ahead
great that's the originally talking
about it that's the full command for -
should be so that can be defeat rised
now right
but there's some cases where it's a
little bit yeah that one I think makes
sense G feet race but does everything
work that I mean it's not just file it's
also URL and - cloud finish love all the
other ones work I don't think that URL
one where it's it needs it needs to
that's a very important case right um
okay so hold on the okay so let's do
future eyes this oh gosh oh no that's
all that junk um okay so the important
thing here again I think let's
concentrate more on the functionality
than documentation probably if you'da
future eyes it that means it's going to
be documented in for version twelve even
though that may not work yet what may
not work the URLs the things that
Garrett is said weren't gonna work yet
well then they'll be bugs okay that's
that shouldn't be too hard to talk uh
parity of code to download from okay
okay so hold on let's let's we have a
number of comments on the live stream um
how would I run notebook is a demon
it's basically starting its own kernel
and keeping it running that would be the
first case because if you have you know
if the test notebook doesn't exits you
know if there's a while loop but then
that that's just gonna keep running okay
I think I mean for example a computer
search and a notebook you want to keep
running for a long time maintaining
search state and logging things but not
showing the notebook yeah then the
notebook has to be written in a way that
it doesn't it exits with a while true
loop or some other looping I think well
yeah if it's doing a big search then
it's doing a big search but it wants to
the notebook would then spawn out it
would write notebooks itself yeah can do
anything a notebook can throw but it did
the first case is you know he's headless
today so the comment here is that
notebook star star star notebook star
functions don't typically work in the
pure kernel is that true still so if I
run if I go to a pure kernel right and I
run let's hope I get to appeal kernel um
let's see
well there's a using furnance function
right well ok hold on hold on so if I go
to a pure kernel here so hopefully I can
do this something and it's 11 3 that's
okay that's matter ok so what should I
do here you can do using friends like
this and open brackets and then let me
see if we have a good example
there's no examples that's not good you
can do something like create document or
something I don't know if it's gonna
happen here I'll create a document
headless Lee it's for like off 100k what
the heck is that
that's not from the kernel that's
something that's running what the heck
is that I don't know what it is but it's
well we can take a screenshot I
investigated but I think that's just
some indexing servers that you have
running because she just created the
document oh that might be wrong
Scofield's you know notebook indexer
thingy okay there's something wrong it
says error unsupported compress or yeah
a car like a screenshot of that but so
this so I don't think I I really knew or
understood this and I think um the folks
on our live stream didn't know it and I
don't think I would have known it either
so if I say using front-end yeah did
it's documented using for an end so
that's but is it documented in the
notebook well that is a pretty lame
piece of documentation I might say so
well okay so so wait a minute but this
doesn't say yeah this needs to say that
a standalone Colonel you need to use
using front number why do you need using
front end why does it even care why did
you just have it just work why do we
need that um think some functions want
to just work without the front end and
and sometimes like what would you do
with rasterize for example I think
rasterize should do whatever it does and
and I mean in other words rasterize
should work but my point is that
rasterize I mean if I say um you know
let's say rasterize 1 or square root of
2 graphics of disk or something yeah no
actually I think restaurant uses that
using finance yeah ok right so I mean I
think that's what should happen by
default for everything now the only
question is I see the issue is this ok
the slightly subtle as sewers is it the
same front end do you have a front end
moon so to speak orbiting your Wolfram
script and I think the answer has to be
yes
so I'm saying ok so here let me try the
following thing if I say system open of
% 1 oh that's very interesting why
didn't that work why didn't that hand
that to the operating system that's the
object that's not see it is the thing it
is the thing if I say input form a
percent one I'll get that
what the heck is that what the heck is
that what is that what is that why does
it say Mathematica what is Mathematica
so what is this ok
that's the disservice that that's the
front end that using for an basically
uses okay so we need to fix that right
yeah yeah yeah but I don't even
understand what it is it's the headless
for an ends basically strolling to it
yeah this is this is about like a loo or
another front end person in here because
this is 12-15 find blue
yeah okay okay yeah yeah I already
warned you about this that this would
happen sir um okay but this this should
just
I mean system open of that should work
right I mean if I say something like run
I think but but if I say something like
you know run you know date or something
okay I get the date fine ah yeah system
open on the notebook works it's just
that it what it's not implemented is the
notebook object because it's not even
saved yet right I mean there's nothing
on the on your hard disk
I see station of you know but we're
gonna need that function right we're
gonna need a function that from that's
exactly a function we're gonna need is
from a kernel bring this up in the
Windows Server right right
so I mean essentially this is a note but
actually win it what happens if I say
notebook open of percent one why didn't
that work using using furnance into rap
using front ends around it but that's
not gonna be visible again because you
know that's that's gonna use the
headless front end so it's well known oh
dear oh that's really confusing you see
the dollar notebooks thing okay if
there's an orbiting if there's a kind of
a service front-end which there is here
the notion of whether dollar notebooks
is true or false is less clear
I mean it's false it should be false
because not you're not operating through
a notebook front end so that's what
dollar notebooks means right but you do
need the ability to pop up a notebook
from the kernel do you have a notebook
in your directory there that you can
open which is system open within the
file name I mean I
that I expect to work I would expect
that would work too so just anything
attends in and be great where would I
find that downloads maybe do you have
the notebook you just the standalone
applications notebook did you say that
in your - folder where did that go what
the agenda notebook I could look at
downloads okay so let's say no you have
to backspace since that's not it's not a
for an instant okay set directory to
downloads okay so now if I say file
names um start over and be right let's
say oh gosh wow this is a primitive
world okay all right let's try so one of
them should be your stand alone -
applications thing well let's do the
very last one so let's say notebook open
so what do I say so using closed system
open you don't need you system open off
that thing should open in a new front
end so yeah all right that I did not
expect to go wrong well so so I say
using front end let's know that that
should have worked okay if you do system
open with with a particular file with an
extension that should just work on the
windows that works just fine well I did
that but it didn't work I know that
that's just a bug okay alright okay but
so to me we're gonna need something
which from within a standalone kernel
okay what should notebook open do should
no [ __ ] open actually display something
on your screen or should notebook open
do something different so there's
options right I think there's visible
false and true stats not beautiful
opener yeah you're absolutely right
right I don't know no no you're
absolutely right it's right here else
nope so so that means okay great great
so notebook open with with by default
has visible true
so notebook open in a script should just
open a notebook in the Windows server if
it can right now we may need a variable
to determine whether a window silver is
present okay but that's what this should
do and I mean we should untangle the
using front end horror from the other
stuff but let's keep going with the rest
of this okay okay so that's execute a
notebook but - UI
okay what are you saying for - UI
it opens it so you can actually see the
user interfaces that's basically
notebook open it okay pull from script
just opens to notebook so you can see it
okay but but that then is a different
well from script - notebook the big
question is yeah should Russia should
shoot invisible and run I think I think
there's two orthogonal things the
notebook being visible maybe shooting
notebook running right yeah there's also
a question of in what way does the
notebook run notebook evaluate has
options that for instance lets you
restrict the evaluation to just
initialization cells for instance I see
well okay so what this really is in the
wolfram script world we have - code
right - crowing - file they just run
what's in those things rights and then
their [ __ ] but you should be able to run
notebooks you should be able to just you
know like there's a I I claim that the
missing thing here is the thing called -
display which is - UI we're just you
know I kinda thing that's missing here
is something that would be like Wolfram
script oh gosh I have no idea how to get
that correct cell in there well from
script - display file yeah no no no just
display all display does is it displays
the thing it doesn't evaluate anything
just out brings the notebook up see what
I'm saying yeah but it's file can only
be a notebook in that case right like
weed when the Wolfman script does not
print I mean she did print out seems a
little bit weird - I mean you should not
print a file if it's just a WI file okay
fair enough
well maybe we need a term which isn't um
look maybe what we need is - interactive
or something but - and director doesn't
seem like it takes a payload - launch
could just - open yeah
he'll pick open open up right yeah it's
not bad um okay well from script - open
a notebook okay um and then okay then
that's the thing that brings up okay so
now what that's what clunk collapses
those two options on the left right - -
do I - notebook a club yes justjust -
open opens the notebook but does not
evaluate it yeah that's the way to bring
up notebooks and
locations okay now if you want to
evaluate the notebook you would say
after you did - open notebook well what
would you do what what what happens to
code that occurs after that I'll a - run
maybe or something where - actually cute
if when we're writing this in the
front-end you'd have the result of this
would be a pointer to the notebook which
then you operate on great underneath I
get back a notebook so I can do don't
book evaluate of it if we want to go
hold on so
what would happen if there's a hash-bang
wolfram script - open notebook and then
there's code what would that do
not sure understand that case what does
it do with - code in that case in that
case I think it tries to run the content
is code so like if you have - file that
it assumes the content is the file so
maybe it should open the current content
is in a book it's a really peculiar case
oh yeah it is a little bit old on hold
on hold on hold on
because I can see a case where what
people want the
oh boy I'm gonna run out of time here
this is really bad we're gonna have to
continue this um
okay hold on
and what about in the cloud - open
notebook - cloud
not sure if the cloud is scriptable like
that yet like you cannot just open a
browser open a notebook in and have it
run no wait a minute but you can because
what you can do it's the equivalent of
just going to a cloud object and opening
it if that notebook was in a cloud
object you could just open it right
that's what the cloud does the Wolfram
script Amin Wolfen scripted launched
like a browser at the particular
notebook location or cloud object
location and then what then it will just
show it to you I mean you might have to
login right I mean just it just be there
in the air in the UI so if it's just any
URL HUD I confirm it's a notebook yes
you know thinking thinking thinking I
mean it depends how you spell it isn't
any URL that notebook thing is a file
name right okay if it's a URL right then
what you're doing is if it has the wrong
mime type you're out of there right
otherwise you are pulling that URL into
the cloud and displaying it which is a
very useful thing to do and it's
something that we want to do in the
cloud itself right this is a thing we've
been wanting is something which is a
different thing right well we have an
actual I think what we want to do is we
want to have something where it goes you
know all from cloud comm slash and then
there's a URL that you can give here
there is some other random URL right
that it will go and try and essentially
copy to the cloud and open there am I
making sense an image from a different
place and interests as science and
Wolfram cloud I'll check to it yes yes
it just leaves it into a cloud object
and then opens it with whatever mime
type it's supposed to open it with okay
okay so that allows you to you know if
if it's just a way of getting notebooks
displayed right I think it's what we're
using for the github thing is something
very much like that crazy so Luke and
you can you speak to that John is the
person who knows about the github stuff
I unfortunately don't I think that's
what it does so now I know that there is
something where you can do it like that
but it's it's it's would be the way I
remember it is that that would just be
an API function and I used to you know
question mark URL equals that's fine
that's fine it's fine it's fine let's
find something yeah but I mean then then
this Wolfram script thing and with a
dash cloud would basically just do that
just go to the cloud use this yes just
using that ah no just said that is cool
that API okay but let's let's look over
here um I do agree that there are things
like how largely I mean that there are
endless options which we could in
principle set for that notebook like
where it is on the screen and all kinds
of stuff right right great so I have to
look at it more like the to positioning
in there right that doesn't matter
if you want to build some sort of custom
application from her yes yes but I mean
I I'm not sure that we should put all
that stuff in the command line I thought
the way we were making that stuff work
was that the actual Wolfram script file
contained a thing that says what was the
name of the function that says basically
notebook open I mean what's so
long as the notebook open thing just
works right all you need to do is to say
hash-bang Wolfram script notebook open
and then the name of the notebook you
know so you're saying don't go too far
in the direction with the window size
and all those options I wouldn't do that
I wouldn't do it so it's up to the
notebook to know where it's supposed to
live yes but but what I'm saying is you
can just script that by saying instead
of saying this well from script - open
notebook what you instead of doing is
you're saying you know hash-bang will
from script okay and then the actual
payload is notebook open of blah blah
blah window margins arrow blah blah blah
am I making sense yeah I mean trying to
read doesn't that's an actual option for
a notebook open it that's it it is it is
I mean underneath I'm converting these
themes and window size options
essentially to something that will fit
in this notebook open so it's it's
similar yeah right all right I mean
notebook open is it'll take any notebook
option I think that's right isn't it
little yes I believe so
on desktop I don't know what's the done
hmm I understand but what this is doing
is I'm not I wasn't talking about cloud
here I'm talking about in this case
right okay so the
this is that you know book open will
return a the notebook object you know
the point so you could you could have
you know a dozen more lines here that
absolutely there were things to it yeah
right exactly this is the right way to
do this okay
and this is only a courtesy well from
script - open notebook it's just a
courtesy that is the equivalent of this
okay and then their dress okay hold on
there's one thing here that we do need
to specify right which is the UI
specification like the menu theme right
so even in this case this needs to say
something about the I think we should
call it UI theme look at that the agenda
that's the next item on the agenda okay
so then I think it's - UI theme blah
blah blah and that means if it launches
the UI this is the UI to launch well
actually no no no no no no I'm taking
that back I'm taking that back - UI
means launcher UI right because you know
whether you want to launch UI or not
that will launch a UI and then it will
open that notebook into that UI well the
problem with that is we want it to start
the UI with that notebook open that's
the issue what I'm saying Lou do you
understand that point can you repeat
that I'm sorry I was distracted for just
that second okay look we wants it to be
able to we don't just want it to open a
UI and then you know you know lazily
bring up a notebook so to speak we wants
it to open a UI in which the notebook
has been you know we've got that figured
out already with wolfram scripts that
that's you know it what is that the
screenshots what you see on the left
they're all coming up without welcome
screens without any sort of you know
startup screens without any you know
that's using okay but but what with the
new proposal for how this works how does
this how do you get would do the same
thing it would not it would not show the
you know startup splash thing it would
no I understand that but if you need to
use all these windows
margins and all that kind of stuff well
scroll down on in the agenda where
there's a couple of different themes one
with menus one without menus I know that
I'm not talking about that I'm talking
about if you if you need to place the
window at a particular place on the
screen or use other weird options here I
would expect that notebook open with
options we'll do that moving before
making a notebook visible I know that
but I'm saying I'm saying Lou you don't
get to use notebook open because this is
the initial launch of the UI right so
this thing it's convincing here comes up
silently Steven it comes up silently
oh it does right that's what I'm trying
to say that there is no starter splash
screen there's no welcome screen there's
nothing okay so when it launches you
know the first thing you'll ever get to
see is one of those notebooks I mean I
can show you if you don't believe me no
I believe you okay um this is nice okay
on the live stream Ethan is asking for a
- daemon option which restarts the
notebook and keeps running it now we
have that notion of a persistent session
in wolfram script don't we don't think
we quite have like a persistent session
well we only had that idea of a persist
yeah we had an idea for it it's
interesting because there's a couple
different ways to do it you could
connect to an existing open session run
things or try to start a new one but
what what Ethan is asking for is and
it's a very reasonable thing to ask for
that there is a server process that just
keeps on trying to run a notebook
now of course the question is if it
crashes and wants to restart what does
it actually restart you get what I'm
asking I mean in other words it's not
obvious where how it keeps going so to
speak right I see so this is the other
cases if you restart your computer and
it wants to restart running I mean that
is much more like that
tasks mechanism great yet separate thing
I think that's more like running a
continuous task which I think now the
question of whether Wolfram script can
launch a continuous task is a different
issue okay let's let's have a very
very quick look at this and then
unfortunately I have to go but um all
right what are these so this is d
Wolfram language function which takes
contents like you know any sort of
expression but there's different types
and creates the appropriate Wolfram
language script file which you can then
run from the command line to do you know
the right things either this work
doesn't work yet but you know this is
just a project as I understand it
there's a really rough prototype I have
but it's not it's really roughly almost
okay it's like but so but okay okay so I
want you to do like if you have an image
right the Wolfram script just bring up
you know a small good hold on hold on so
let's take this case here okay in this
case here it's gonna do the same type of
thing as a Wolfram script - API
exactly okay where is it going to bring
up
thinkers to case there's command line
oriented cases where I just textual you
know back and forth right no but I mean
how do you use this one so let's take
this one here do you use it by calling
Wolfram script - API or is this now you
just take AP I'd function wls and then
you know - x2 or whatever Wow quite a
bit here notice in Wolfram script you
have to - type - args so if you can just
type - X - that's one of if if what you
can do there is type - x2 and then what
you're seeing is something that ok write
that the - arcs thing is what I'm
talking about I'm not sure if the other
one works well but I mean we could
imagine something where it works like an
API where the API is um because normally
in an API you get those underscore
things right so in this case what I can
do is I can get that type number and I
can build the script with that as - ARDS
inside of the scripts okay but okay so
this is clearly very useful to have a
command line deploy of an API function
that's clearly useful in the content
oriented cases that you've listed there
well like a form function what an earth
would that do
would that actually bring up an
interface where like a command line
interface where you type in you know
three and then it okay it uses the form
page stuff that already exists in the
Fernet know in the front end
but so it's bringing up a notebook thing
it's not bringing up something that's
that's a raw command line right with ask
yes right we haven't thought about that
one yet there could be a cloud version
as well if it's a cloud deploy right
there could also be a form page that is
there could be a form page that works
like an old-fashioned UNIX program right
where you just type in you know you type
in X it prompts you for X you type in
two it gives a result it prompts you for
X again you type in three it gives your
result etc
right but I dia was that we just
leverage the existing code that's
already exists I think what you're
describing in this code is I agree but
the existing code is some kind of grand
JavaScript animal in the clouds yes but
there's I think most of these things
also have a foreign end version of they
do but whether whether they have a
version that works in the command-line
front end I don't know if they'd if that
works and it may then then we are home
free there listen really unfortunately I
have to go um but uh I would I mean this
is wonderful this is really interesting
can we try to continue this the next few
days and I mean it's gonna take a little
bit of time to grind through this I
think make sense yep okay okay
there oh wait a minute um um okay
unfortunately yeah I really love to go
on with this now but unfortunately I
have to go to something else um okay
okay okay to be continued
okay thanks thanks for comments on the
livestream have a good weekend everyone